the 20 series is pretty expensive
especially the r-tx 20 atti
but don't be expecting a price drop to
be coming anytime soon
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus so nvidia often
likes to charge an extra fee or like an
early adopters fee for the first year
that they release a new product because
in most cases most of the people who are
buying their GPUs in the first year will
most likely buy their gpus regardless of
the price as a result india takes
advantage of the situation and tries to
make more profit off of each unit of
their cell for example with the gtx 1088
launched for an MSRP of $700 and a one
year later the gtx 980ti came out which
then replaced at seven others and the
gtx 10a had dropped to $600 so we may
see something like that with the
architects 20 series as well for example
right now the architects 2080 cost $800
but in a year from now
it may drop to $7 but it's very unlikely
for it to drop anything until at least a
year so currently we are definitely
having to deal with an early adopters
fee and unfortunately that fee is not
going to be going away for at least a
year secondly you have to keep in mind
invidious target audience nvidia is not
trying to target the average consumer
with the 20 series at least not that
cars I have been shut off so far Nvidia
is targeting the enthusiasts who want
the best gaming experience possible
barely spend some extra money to get it
currently on the top level 20 series
GPUs have even been announced and there
are still a lot of tensors inventory as
a result the 10 series is what NVIDIA is
targeting at the masses that 23 is sort
of a premium product lineup so at least
for the next couple of months MBA is
going to maintain that sharp distinction
between the 10 and 20 series thirdly
Nvidia still has a good amount of
inventory of the 10 series and as a
result they want to get rid of that
before they go on to 20 series and so
they really have no rush in getting to
20 series right now from invidious point
of view if a consumer buys a tensor is
GPU they're able to get rid of that old
inventory and if they buy a 20 series
GPU then that's feeding their high
profit margins
so either way it's beneficial and they
don't really care as a result Invidia
isn't no rush to convince you that you
should buy a twenty series GPU they were
probably most likely actually want to
concentrate on getting the ten series
inventory out first before they fully
concentrate on the 20 series firstly
NVIDIA has no competition from anybody
Amy Vega barely matches the performance
of the top level 10 Series GPUs and it
will most likely not even come close to
performance with a 20 series GPUs and
asked for AMD Navi we really don't know
many details right now but if anything
it may match the performance of the 20
series for a better price if AMD Navi is
released for a cheaper price with the
same performance of the 10 series then
nvidia may consider a price top earlier
but as of now there really is no motor
for Nvidia to do a price drop because
they really have no competition
and finally there are other factors
other than just Nvidia being greedy as
well real time rate racing took me a
long time to develop and it probably had
substantial development costs the 20
series is not just a traditional
architectural upgrade there are a lot of
technological upgrades as well like DL
SS deep learning super sampling and the
four mentioned real-time rate racing as
a result the higher prices that we are
seeing with the 20 series may be a
result of the higher development costs
and finally you have to consider the
state of the DRAM market due to the
August 6 memory is already a lot more
expensive than GDR 5x and gddr5 memory
and with the Infinity Ram market right
now it just makes it even worse for the
price of jitta or 6 memory and thus that
could also be contributing to the high
20 series GPU prices as a result in
video will most likely want to recoup
their extra development cost for a
real-time rate racing before they
dropped a price of the 20 series GPUs
overall India likes to charge an early
dopplers fee for around an ear they're
targeting the premium market they still
have a lot of inventory of the 10 series
they have no competition from AMD and it
may have costs a lot more to develop
this series in any previous series and
unfortunately none of these issues are
easily resolvable and as a result is
going to take a while before 22news GPU
prices drop there may be some small dips
and
like up to $50 over the holiday season
of this year but ask for the MSRP of the
20 series that is pretty much going to
remain solid over the next year unless
Amy brings up something really big but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think the 20
series actually fairly priced based up
the DRAM market situation right now and
extra development costs that it took in
media to develop a 20 series or do you
just think it's Nvidia being greedy yet
make sure comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments that I'm curious as to what you
guys think to make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video make sure to like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]